as we watch this pandemic spread and we
want also the reaction to the pandemic
from different governments from
different organizations we are seeing a
true symbolism happens moment and often
symbolism also happens in a world where
symbolism seems to have been forgotten
and because it is forgotten there
actually might be a tendency to go into
extremes and to manifest the extremes of
different aspects of symbolism and so
one of the questions that has been
coming up has been the question of
borders the question of purity the
question of exchange in terms of the
economy and in terms of dealing with
other people and trying to find the
balance between the two so we're going
to look a little bit once again at the
symbolism of these different terms and
try to understand how it is we can avoid
falling into excesses
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so we have all accepted it seems that
all the governments of the world and all
the different societies seems seem to
have accepted that the solution to this
problem is to to emphasize borders it is
to create borders at every levels of
reality and especially at the personal
level now when you see how people are
emphasizing a lot of people have
wondered why is it that people who are
more left-leaning and their politics are
seem to be emphasizing more the personal
border that is self isolating whereas
people who are more right leaning seem
to not want to emphasize that so much
and rather emphasize creating a border
at the state level or at different
communal levels now this is not that
difficult to understand now if you are
someone who is pro state or pro
globalization or Pleau or pro you know
as the left-leaning people in politics
tend to be then you you realize even
intuitively without necessarily thinking
about it that there is a danger of of
clamping down at different levels of
identity and you don't want that because
you want the state you want the
government level to be the strongest and
so in order to do that the the best
solution is to bring the border down to
the radical individual right down to as
close to the individual as possible so
that you are actually working to your
advantage and you are disassembling the
intermediary steps you so it is possible
to use this kind of clamping down of the
border to the individual to break down
all the intermediary organizations we
have churches we have businesses we have
all these intermediary identities that
exist between us and let's say the state
and in this time of pandemic when
borders are reappearing and everybody is
moving
- a sense of purity there is an
intuitive fear that people will will
back down will come down into ethnical
identities at ethnic identities or
religious identities you know even even
in terms of businesses or in terms of
community groups or whatever it is
rather what they want even like I said
it's not necessarily planned out for
everybody what they want is to break
bring the the identity down to the
individual so that the state level will
have the most freedom to act and to
impose its laws and to impose its power
and it actually might open up a a
growing of the state level it might give
power to government that we had never
seen before as we are all isolated in
our houses and the government is putting
in measures of social distance distance
iation using cell phones to geo
localized people you know using vaccines
to tag people we've seen discussion
about that with Bill Gates all of this
is is is this is bringing down to the
individual and wanting to emphasize the
state is running a very dangerous risk
of creating a tyrannical state so we
need to be attended to that and to be
cautious um but the problem is that
because of iris is in a way a virus
moves in all kinds of ways the other
solution which is to all come together
or to come together in communities it
might make the virus it might emphasize
the virus now that is that is of course
a problem but it we're not even sure if
that which one is going to be the best
solution because as they tell us
everybody is going to get this or most
people are going to get this and so is
it better to to clamp down on the
individual increase the state or is it
better to to get come together into
communities so that as communities we
have the resources and the power let's
say the the comfort and the the strength
as communities to deal with the fallout
of that then the death that this is
going to bring because obviously people
are going to die one way or the other
and so this is something we need to be
attentive to the other thing we need to
be attentive to is that we used to live
just a few months ago we lived in a
world of globalization of global trade
of tourism of openness of diversity all
of these things were the values that
were being espoused by our governments
especially here in Canada it would
became almost a caricature and so now
what we're seeing is this this clamp
down but we also and the clamp down is
kind of absolute and there is a
compassion element to the clamp down
there is a there's a desire to climb
down because of compassion and because
of this it almost seems like the now the
question of being open to the exterior
because one of the aspects of being open
to the exterior is of course trade we
need to never forget that and so as we
clamp down in our smaller identities we
are going to be reducing trade now we
are going to be reducing the things that
come from the outside one of the things
that comes from the outside no matter
what level you are dealing with is food
food comes from the outside food is an
integration of potentiality into your
body and so it is something it is a food
is something like something that needs
to break that to be broken down into a
kind of potential or chaos you really
put it into your body and then it
becomes your body right so it's taking
from the outside and constituting your
body from it and that's the same with
trade you exchange with a stranger in
order to receive things from them that
you will integrate into your identity
that you will bring into yourself we
could be objects it you know it can be
all kinds of can be services all these
things are related to being in contact
with the outside now because we don't
it's as if we moved from an extreme of
openness and openness to trade globalism
all of this stuff and now we
moved into an extreme of closing down we
run the risk if we're not careful of
destroying trade and trade is also life
if you do not have the resources you
need to continue you are going to die
one of the and because in the other
opposite side we had made ourselves
completely dependent from the outside
it's not sure that we have solutions to
deal with this problem one of the issues
we're seeing here now in Canada is that
usually people who were picking fruit
and picking the vegetables in the farms
were all coming from the outside were
all immigrants from from South America
mostly and so now what are we going to
do if we cut off this potentiality then
we do not have the capacity the
potential to feed ourselves is that
what's going on so we need to be
attentive to this symbolic swings
because as people are unaware and they
the the problem with symbolic the
problem with swings and the problem with
a lack of symbolic understanding is we
almost become slaves to the symbolic
process and so as we move from openness
into this purity I told you in my late
last videos that one of the problems is
that people forget the other side as
they move into a moment of purity they
they can't even it's like they're
another person it's a whole other aspect
of their person which is being made
awake and they can't even remember what
it was like to be the other person and
so because of that now all of a sudden
the other person becomes dangerous evil
or whatever and they don't realize that
you need to always have this balance
between the two so if we look only to
the purity side into protecting
ourselves from our from the virus and we
completely ignore out of a desire you
know out of this radical swing of the
pendulum we completely desire the the
necessity for trade and the necessity
for receiving things from the outside in
order to be able to sustain ourselves
then we are also going to die we're
gonna die from an excess of purity that
is not impossible
that's what allergies are
allergies are excesses of purity that is
your body is not able is always wanting
to fight off everything that comes from
the outside and is incapable of
discerning what is needed from the
outside and what isn't so we definitely
need to be attentive to that as we move
forward but I would say be attentive to
what is happening to what is happening
to yourself those of you who have kind
of developed some kind of symbolic
thinking and you will see how the
analogies that I tried to portray for
you how there is an analogy between the
by between the biological reality of
dealing with foreign bodies and dealing
with viruses and things coming from the
outside there's there there's a analogy
between that and the social level and
we're going and there's a rillette
there's an analogy between that and the
spiritual level and so if you notice for
example now all of a sudden our
governments are telling us to start
wearing masks and to to protect
ourselves in pondering the reality of
the face mask and understanding why is
it that you need to wear the face mask
on the one hand to protect yourselves
from the outside and on the other to
protect the outside from you is going to
help you understand why is it that we
have veils for example in the temple in
the tabernacle how the reason that there
are veils in the temple or the
tabernacle or the reason why in
Scripture and in many traditions people
ask women to wear veils is exactly the
same reason at a different level of
reality of course as why people are
asked to wear face masks that is on the
one hand and and it really is it really
goes both ways so in the temple one of
the reasons why you want the the temple
to have veils is to on the one hand
protect from the outside that is protect
from the the profanation from the
outside protect from strange strangers
who are not meant to be in the mystery
from denaturing the mystery so you're
protecting the glory of God from the
outside but you're also protecting the
world from the glory of God as I've
show you in my my video on the
coronavirus and the relationship the
pandemics and the relationship in the
Bible when the Ark of the Covenant moves
out into the foreign land it causes
disease and so you need to protect the
outside from the ark as well the glory
becomes becomes the disease once it is
on the outside this movement between
glory and death
and so we need to also be aware of that
as we understand why it is that
symbolically why it is that now suddenly
we're being asked to wear these face
masks and how all of it is just always a
continuation and a playing out of the
patterns of reality so I'm gonna try to
be making a few more videos on this
subject as the situation moves forward
if you want to ask questions I'm not
gonna talk about this exclusively for
sure but be sure to tune into my Q&A
this month and hopefully we can deal
with some more questions that people
might have on this subject in the Q&A as
well and I would say please if you can
also subscribe to the clips channel I
will put a link to the clip channel in
the description a lot of the content
strange content that you've never seen
things that come from interviews that
I've done are all kind of being brought
into the clip channel they're doing a
great job and it's you know short you
know five to ten minute even - three
minutes - - 10-15 minute clips on all
organized by subjects so thanks
everybody for your support stay safe
stay aware don't stay too safe be
attentive to what's going on and I'll
see you very soon
[Music]